valérie milot croit rêver la musicienne
joue sur une part qui lui paraissait
inaccessible
je suis tombé sur cet instrument l'un
qui est vraiment un son exceptionnel
j'ai vraiment dès les premières notes
que j'ai joué sur ce point là j'ai eu
vraiment un coup de foudre très intense
la musicienne de 33 ans qui compte huit
albums à son actif et de nombreuses
tournées tant au canada qu'à l'étranger
a trouvé cette harpe
il ya un an à chicago dans la plus
grande manufacture de art pour mon jeu
vraiment tombé sur un instrument qui
était d'une beauté époustouflante pour
moi le look était c'était eux qui posent
le problème en fait parce que c'est ça
qui fait avec les soins étaient très
cher la marque compte cent vingt mille
dollars
si sa décoration qui lui confère autant
de valeur il faut que les artisans et un
an de travail pour intercalé les
feuilles d'or le bois et le mécanisme
complexe des erp comme celle ci il en
existe que 13 dans le monde grâce aux
mécènes et hommes d'affaires roger
dubois la harpiste peut en profiter
tu ai demandé s'ils voyagent
sa collection puis finalement il a fini
par accepter à mon grand bonheur
le mécène souhaite demeurer discret et
laisser toute la lumière à l'instrument
et à la musicienne mais lucien bouchard
connaît bien roger tu vois la collection
du mécène comprend une centaine
d'instruments dont huit sont prêtés aux
musiciennes d'orchestre symphonique de
montréal
pour lucien bouchard qui est le
président du conseil d'administration de
l'ouest m
le mécénat est fondamentale j'ai répondu
monsieur nasser pour la même chose non
plus par exemple 20 à 25 pour ça je
voudrais être le huitième nous vient du
missionnaire d'origine valeur à gauche
actions ou les parts mais je dirais que
depuis maintenant plusieurs années c'est
devenu important également chez les
francophones qui réussissent en affaire
le juge marc est de plus en plus
maintenant que le précieux instrument
lui prêter valérie milot en prend grand
soin ça va être plus organisé un petit
peu plus surveillez aussi parce que ça
vient avec un certain stress quand même
c'est certain mais c'est certain la
première fois où est ce que je n'ai mis
dans mon jeu vous seront que j'allais
beaucoup plus tranquillement
mais valérie milot compte bien sortir sa
précieuse harpe le plus souvent possible
pour en faire profiter les autres
les amateurs de musique pourront
l'entendre et aussi l'admiré pour la
première fois lors d'un concert avec le
sm à la maison symphonique le 18 avril
ici julie jasmin boudreau radio canada
montréal